in 1984 a movie about a killer cyborg
turned an Austrian bodybuilder into a
global Superstar The Terminator movies
ended up changing the world and no
person had their life altered more than
Arnold
Schwarzenegger it's impossible to
imagine the Terminator without Arnold
Schwarzenegger it seems like the part
was pretty much made for him and there's
no doubt that he was the perfect choice
to take on the role however
Schwarzenegger was initially hesitant to
sign on he originally wanted to play
Kyle ree the resistance fighter who goes
back in time to protect Sarah Connor hey
I think this guy's a couple cans short
of a six-pack he still had some ideas
for how The Terminator should be played
though so we had a discussion with
director James Cameron Schwarzenegger
recalled I said there should be no joy
no gratification no kind of Victory lap
of any sort just the mission complete
you don't feel any emotion about it one
way or
another no I have to stay functional
until the mission is complete Cameron
liked Schwarzenegger's idea and saw that
he genuin Ely understood the character
so he ended up offering Schwarzenegger
the parts the bodybuilder wasn't on
board at first as he didn't want to play
a villain and the role didn't have many
lines but after spending some time
thinking about it he was persuaded into
making the decision that would define
his entire
career your
clothes give them to me now the
Terminator wasn't shortz Egger's first
major film that would be Conan the
Barbarian in which he starred as Conan
himself he had already begun making a
name for himself in Hollywood before
meeting with James Cameron and becoming
the
T800 Conan what is best in life to crush
your enemies see them driven before you
and they hear the lamentation of your
women despite that Schwarzenegger
credits the Terminator as the film that
turned him into a genuine action star
Conan did well at the box office but it
just didn't earn the same Universal
Acclaim that the Terminator did plus
Schwarzenegger went on to appear in
several more Terminator films after the
success of the original while he only
returned to his role as Conan for one
sequel as the actor put it during a
panel discussion at San Diego ComicCon
Terminator was the movie that really
launched my action movie career from
that moment on everything has changed in
my life Conan may have been schwarzen
Egger's initial breakthrough role but
the Terminator brought him to a whole
new level of Fame and cemented his
status as an action star in the public
eye the Terminator became more than just
a film it was a cultural phenomenon and
Arnold Schwarzenegger was at the center
of it all his few lines were quoted all
the time along with impressions of his
unmistakable accent up and at them up
and at them up and at them up and at
them up and atam up and at them the
Terminator was eventually selected for
preservation in the National film
registry for its cultural significance
and the American Film Institute declared
the T800 as one of the best movie
villains of all time why did the
Terminator makes such a huge impact
Schwarzenegger has a theory the
Terminator represents the inner rage
that people people often try to suppress
his character was an emotionless monster
and he could do whatever he wanted
without facing the consequences that a
normal person would as Schwarzenegger
told Men's Health people really admire
the character because he was able to do
things they all wanted to do everyone
wants to wipe out a police station when
they get mad at the
police Schwarzenegger was already in
incredible shape when he began filming
the Terminator but to really commit to
the character he had to pick up a whole
new set of skills after all he was
playing a character whose whole body
could function as a weapon with the sole
mission of finding and killing Sarah
Connor that's why he needed to learn how
to use a variety of weapons he would be
spending a lot of time in front of the
camera with a gun in his hand
Schwarzenegger wrote in his Memoir Total
Recall I worked with guns every day
before we filmed and for the first two
weeks of filming I practiced stripping
and reassembling them blindfolded until
the Motions were
automatic you know your weapons buddy
Schwarzenegger also spent a lot of time
at his shooting range practicing with
with different weapons he said that it
was a challenge but he had to get those
techniques down if he wanted to play a
convincing killing machine Jesus you're
going to kill that guy of course I'm a
Terminator Arnold Schwarzenegger came to
the United States with pretty much
nothing and clawed his way up to the top
so it's easy to see why someone like him
might feel like he was solely
responsible for his own success however
when he reflects on his early years in
Hollywood he knows that James Cameron is
partially to thank for his achievements
on Cameron's birthday Schwarzenegger
posted a kind Tri to the director who
changed the trajectory of his life he
shared Cameron's original story boards
for the Terminator which depicted the
T800 as an imposing villain somewhere
between man and machine as
Schwarzenegger wrote you're a big reason
that I can never call myself self-made
this early storyboard you drew for
Terminator reminds me of your big vision
and I cherish it Cameron's support has
clearly humbled Schwarzenegger and
taught him that in Hollywood no one
makes it all on their
own if there's one line everyone knows
from the Terminator it's the one that
the TA 800 says before driving through
the sight of a police station I'll be
back surprisingly though Schwarzenegger
was not a huge fan of the way Cameron
had written the line he objected to the
contraction in the phrase telling the
writer and director that he thought The
Terminator should say I will be back
instead he felt that his version of the
line would sound more like a machine
speaking the words predictably Cameron
was stubborn about sticking to his
script reminding Schwarz Ander that he
was the writer and his judgment should
be trusted once the film came out the
actor realized that Cameron's instinct
were right all along as he told Esquire
after I saw it in the movie I was so
thankful to Cameron that was a good
lesson to learn if someone is a good
writer stick to the
script although Schwarzenegger's
physical strength and good work ethic
helped him break into Hollywood
something was holding him back his
strong Austrian accent he told Empire I
wanted to be a leading man but it was
not just that I had an accent it was a
German accent and in America that accent
was scary they wanted to cast me as a
bouncer or a Nazi officer Schwarzenegger
admitted the test audiences for his
early films found his accent frightening
and intimidating he worried that he
wouldn't be able to land the roles he
wanted but that wasn't a concern for
long the success of the Terminator
proved that the very thing casting
directors looked down on Schwarzenegger
for would actually turn out to be an
asset his accent made him unique and he
would eventually get some of those
leading man roles he always wanted the
Terminator wouldn't be the same if it
wasn't for that Unforgettable
voice get out
becoming a movie star is far from
Schwarzenegger's only major
accomplishment in 2003 he entered the
political world when he won a special
election and became the governor of
California he was reelected in 2006 and
returned to acting after his second term
ended in 2011 Schwarzenegger has
admitted that his time as the Terminator
influenced his political career it was
the media that gave him the nickname the
governator but he was more than happy to
reference it during important events and
get some cheers as he joked when I'd go
out to do a political speech everyone is
talking about the carbon footprint and
the global warming and all that that
terminate climate change very simple
it's easier to say that right it's all
from Terminator I could use this stuff
over and
over starring in the first two
Terminator films meant that
Schwarzenegger spent plenty of time
working alongside Cameron as well as
Linda Hamilton who played Sarah Conor
all three finally reunited once again to
produce and act in Terminator dark fate
and Schwarzenegger considers them both
lifelong friends Schwarzenegger will be
the first first person to call Cameron a
control freak but he also accepts that
the successful director almost always
makes the right call Schwarzenegger has
referred to Cameron as the best director
in the world and it's clear that he has
a massive amount of respect for him and
his newer projects although
Schwarzenegger and Hamilton had not
worked together in about 30 years they
were ecstatic about being together on
set once again and returning to their
old roles for dark fate Hamilton told
total film I don't know if I can qualify
it but I know we're both still standing
and there was just a comradeship and a
deep ction I felt this
[Music]
time